du solltest also jetzt gerade lernen
oder arbeiten aber das hier ist ja das
allerletzte youtube-video für heute
studenten syndrom aufschieberitis oder
prokrastination gemeint ist die neigung
arbeit vor sich hin zu schiemann statt
sie direkt zu erledigen
das war im team vorschlag von
schimmelreiter 2 von vor drei monaten
ja wir alle haben schon mal arbeit
vorziehen geschoben nicht wahr und mit
fahrrad hattest noch nicht mal was zu
tun statt lernen ist man ja auch ganz
fleißig im zimmer aufräumen und putzen
und fensterputzen dass wir schon seit
monaten nicht gemacht hauptsache nicht
das machen was man eigentlich tun soll
und da er schon mal hier seit youtube
ist natürlich auch die prokrastination
falle eigentlich wollte er nur ein
wikipedia-artikel nachschauen und schon
schaut ihr ein video über
prokrastination anstatt zu lernen
manche psychologen bringen den hang zur
prokrastination mit
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen in verbindung
zum beispiel das neurotiker aus angst
vorm scheitern prokrastination das
perfektionisten wegen ihrer hohen
ansprüche schlechtes zeitmanagement
mitbringen und 5 mio
es muss perfekt sein oder das sogenannte
sensations sieger zu impulsiv sind um
prioritäten zu setzen und sich leicht
ablenken lassen
los geht's mit der bachelor ich wollte
noch einen song schreiben viele
wissenschaftler aber weisen notorischen
auf jemanden keine typischen
persönlichkeitsmerkmale zu unterscheiden
aber zwischen passiver und aktiver
prokrastination während passive
aufschieber unangenehme aufgaben einfach
nur vermeiden sehen aktive aufschieber
in dem steigenden druck er
ein reiz der ihnen hilft aufgaben
effektiver zu erledigen jetzt bistros
genug letzter in studien zeigten sich
menschen die nicht programmieren wie
auch aktive aufschieber als
selbstbewusste menschen die ihre erfolge
eher auf ihr eigenes können als auf
glückliche zufälle zurückführten passive
prokrastination zeiten häufiger
selbstzweifel und führten ihre erfolge
eher auf äußere einflüsse zurück aber
warum prokrastination videos gucken oder
bei facebook rumhängen bringt uns war
meistens nicht weiter beschert uns aber
viele kleine belohnungs momente
jedes mal wenn wir etwas schönes oder
spaßiges tun wie in unserem gehirn
dopamin ausgeschüttet was uns sagt
nochmal eine hausarbeit abzugeben oder
eine klausur zu schreiben verspricht
zwar eine größere aber nur eine einzige
bildung die außerdem auch noch in der
zwischen fliegt die in einer so dazu uns
zum beispiel mit vielen kleinen videos
sofort zu belohnen als eine große
belohnung in der zukunft anzustreben
außerdem können wir sowieso nicht so gut
einschätzen wie weit die zukunft weg ist
sag ich mal ein original beispiels aus
einer studie
stell dir vor du würdest in 30 jahren in
rente gehen in wie viel jahren würdest
du dann anfangen zu sparen vorzusorgen
okay ich stelle die fragen jetzt anders
stell dir vor du würdest ihm zehn 1950
tagen in rente gehen im wifi tagen
würdest du jetzt anfangen zu sparen
die teilnehmer der studie die zweite
frage gestellt bekam wollten im schnitt
viermal früher mit dem sparen anfängt
als die der ersten frage deswegen müsst
ihr so denken die klausur ist zb in drei
wochen warum denke nicht klausur ist in
21 tagen und wenn ich die wochenenden
nicht lernen möchte sind es nur noch 15
tage 15 tage bringt doch jetzt mal
vieler strittiger als drei wochen oder
sich selbst deadline setzen to do listen
führen und seinen fortschritt
schriftlich dokumentieren hilft ebenso
wie abdeckung quellen bewusstlos zu
werden das heißt vielleicht mal das wlan
aus bzw einen seiten blogger anschalten
mehr tipps gegen prokrastination und für
ein besseres zeitmanagement findet ihr
diese woche übrigens bei uns auf
facebook
also hier
[Musik]
viele deinem schimmelreiter 2 für deine
frage beziehungsweise deinen
themenvorschlag eure fragen wie immer in
die kommentare aber vor allem würde ich
gerne wissen was seid ihr für
progression autoren passive aktive
neurotiker oder gehört ihr zu den
bewundernswerten menschen die gar nicht
programmieren schreibt in die kommentare
wir sehen uns nächste woche
[Musik]